got a girl's number on the on the
highway I airdropped my contacts to her
what you guys are driving side by side
so so she was like a hot chick I caught
her attention and then we ended up like
speeding up and got next to each other
again and I'm telling her like air drop
air drop turn your airdrop on and she's
always like okay all right I clicked it
and then I was like did you did you get
she's like yeah I got it and then she
texted me she was like that was the
smoothest way I've ever gotten a number
oh so what happened after that yeah what
happened after that we texted a little
bit and then and then she was just like
how many people have you done that to
and I was just like what why you got
ruin that [ __ ] yeah how many girls how
many girls have you done so I was like
yo this was actually the cool I've never
done that before this was cool and then
she just you've never done that before
yeah yeah yeah all right guys they're
too smooth I was just like damn this was
a cool moment you're already like losing
trust Chris said how beat is that [ __ ]
how beat is that [ __ ] and that's what
the gynecologist would ask